[Music]
hey friends Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of boy
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
guide you through step by step how to
perform a forwards meteor thumb lead
weave with your POI but before we dive
in I want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
beklonen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so one of the more popular styles of
spinning poi in the past decade has been
taking both POI and spinning them
together controlled by the same hand
this is a type of poi spinning that we
usually refer to as either meteor
spinning or 2.1 hand or just uh 2p1h for
short essentially the idea is that we're
kind of taking a lot of the same
Concepts that we have in say having one
point in each hand and then applying
them to just controlling both of the POI
from that one hand this is great not
only for giving you more options while
you're spinning but also is foundational
for other variations on the Arts such as
using three POI at the same time now a
gentleman reached out to me a few weeks
ago asking me about meteor tutorials and
I realized that I hadn't done one in
quite some time and more to the point
the last time I did a tutorial
specifically on the forwards thumb lead
weave really wasn't a very good one so I
wanted to update my offerings and
hopefully clear up some confusion around
this weave because I actually do find
that is quite challenging to learn so a
really obvious question before we start
how exactly should you be gripping your
two POI in order to spend the meteor
style this is my preferred grip we're
going to use what we call the thumb and
POI that is the one that is closest to
our thumb and we're essentially going to
pinch it between our index finger and
our Thumb in what's usually called the
key grip because you wind up with a
point of control that feels exactly like
inserting a key into a lock the second
POI which is usually referred to as the
pinky endpoint regardless of which
fingers are actually gripping it I like
to grip between my pinky and my ring
fingers I just find that I get a little
bit more control here many people also
like to grip the pinky and POI basically
just between their pinky and the Flesh
of their hand the the end of the Palm
both of these options work this is my
preferred grip okay so most of us who
are familiar with performing a weave
with one POI in each hand doubtlessly
have tried to switch over to doing 2.1
hand and discovered that what happens is
the two POI kind of fall together or
Worse get tangled up together so why
exactly is that well when we're
performing a weave with both of our
hands do you notice how my wrists are
largely immobile as I'm doing it if you
look really really carefully I'm barely
moving my wrists at all I'm just kind of
keeping them hovering out in space and
for the most part using my fingers to
control the movement of poi here now if
I switch to a meteor weave do you see
how all of a sudden now the articulation
of my right wrist has changed completely
rather than just kind of hanging out in
front of myself I'm having to do a lot
of work to twist my wrist back and forth
this is the Big Challenge in learning
how to do a meteor weave so I'm going to
guide you through what I think is a good
way to begin to get that articulation in
your wrist so to do this I'm going to
ask you to think about two movements and
then chain them together the first move
is going to be imagining that you're
taking the top card off of a deck and
flipping it over to show everybody at
the table in order to do this you have
to change the orientation of your hand
from being palmed down to Palm up and
you're bringing all of your fingers
inward past the inside of your wrist to
do so flipping it over like so the
second movement is to imagine that
you've just flipped a coin and you've
caught it in your palm now I don't know
about you all but the way I usually like
to do my coin flips is then to flip them
one more time over so I'm going to take
the coin as it rests in my palm and flip
it over to put it down on the back side
of my other hand so the full motion
we're taking here is to go from Palm up
and swing it around to Palm down so
these are our two emotions taking the
card off the top of the deck and
flipping the coin taking the card off
the top of the deck and flipping the
coin back and forth back and forth so
essentially what this results in is
you're flipping from Palm down to Palm
up bringing your fingers past the inside
of vrs and then switching from Palm up
to Palm down flicking your fingers past
the outside of your wrist we flick
around the inside we flick around the
outside flick around the inside flick
around the outside just play with this
and get a feel for moving your wrist
back and forth between these spots all
right so now let's try this with POI I'm
going to go ahead and have you take both
of your POI and grip them in one hand in
your meteor grip of choice and I want
you to go ahead and take whichever POI
is coming out the thumb end and hold it
with your other hand now we're going to
go ahead and I want you to throw that
Thumb in POI over and around away from
you
you can do a couple practice throws if
you want but what we want to have
eventually happen is think of this as
the moment where we begin flipping that
card off the top of the deck so when I
throw that thumb and POI I want you to
go ahead and show me the card
just like that and hopefully you should
find that the pinky and POI gets moving
as well
if it doesn't you're not putting enough
articulation into flipping that card to
get a proper start for this it's really
important to put a lot of momentum
behind the pinky end think that even as
you're throwing the thumb end over that
your real job is actually to get the
pinky end moving that way you can be
sure that you get good separation
between the two POI as you begin your
meteor wave so give that a few tries
throwing that thumb end over and see if
you can get the pinky into
again see if you can throw that thumb
end over and get the pinky and to follow
it you're going to wind up seeing the
thumb and go back and forth like you do
in a two beat weave in front of you only
this time the pinky end is going to be
following it alright so now let's try
taking both the card off the top of the
deck as well as flipping the coin card
off the top flip the coin card off the
top flip the coin card off the top flip
the coin card off the top flip the coin
this is going to have to happen a little
bit faster than you think it does but if
you can give your wrist some good
articulation you'll also get good
separation between the POI as well if
you find that the POI are starting to
fall together generally speaking that
means that there's not enough
articulation in your wrist really really
really think that you're trying to
separate out your thumb and Pinky trying
to get them to point away from each
other at all times not just the POI but
the fingers themselves one way I
actually kind of like to try and
visualize this is to imagine that the
POI are two siblings and one of them is
waking up in the morning and trying to
drag the other one out of bed that is my
thumb end is the one that is trying to
pull the pinky end up and around to get
active and the pinky end just is not
having it it is doing everything it can
to resist following the thumb end the
more successful you are with this
visualization the better separation
you're going to get between the two ends
awesome so now let me give you some fpv
footage of this
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so once this starts to feel comfortable
I want you to go ahead and practice it
both in wall plane here so that the POI
are going around in front of and behind
you as well as in wheel plane so it
looks like the POI are spinning directly
in front of you on end it's good to have
both options in your wheelhouse as
you're learning this cool was this
helpful would you like to see me cover
more meteor tricks please let me know
down in the comments did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find it and to help
my channel grow
[Music]
foreign
would not be possible without the kind
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon they and the people
listed down in the description helped to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you all so
much for your very generous support and
if you out there watching are not
currently a supporter but you'd like to
become one you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spending and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out some of my other
videos on meteor spinning I will go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of them down in the description as well
as up here on screen if you're watching
on YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here because it is popular amongst
other viewers of my channel so maybe
give that a look as well thanks so much
for watching make sure to get out and
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon
peace